how does it feel to have Tom Hardy cast
as the evil youth there's the sad thing
is is that he won't be part of the MCU
he'll be part of some Sony Universe but
no it's a very exciting time it could be
a really cool movie I think Tom is a
fantastic actor and I really think he
could play that character with a lot of
a lot of energy and fear you know do you
know anything about what's going on with
that or are you completely out I'm not
yeah I'm not involved in that at all
I actually ooh no I can't say that
whoops
well those movies will all take place in
the world that we are now creating for
for you know for Peter Parker I mean
it'll they'll be adjunct to it they may
be different locations but it will still
all be in the same world and they will
be connected to each other as well who
know I can't say like whoops
to you and I know how important he is to
the Marvel Universe I don't know how
important this is for all of us here so
that's what we're doing hey everybody so
I've been getting a lot of requests to
do a spider-man venom video because it
sounds like it's actually confirmed that
Tom Holland will guest star from the way
that people are talking about it and I
love that Tom Holland clip we're way
back when they were promoting spider-man
homecoming people were asking him
questions cuz they had just announced
Tom Hardy as venom so naturally because
Peter Parker is such an important
character for venom they wanted to get
Peter Parker reacting to the news about
who venom was going to be so it sounds
like he went through Marvel media
training and there's like a PR person
from Marvel Studios standing off screen
just pointing a sniper rifle at him like
just don't say anything at all about the
venom movie because we haven't figured
everything out yet so if you think it's
weird that he does not waste a breath
when he says oh absolutely not venom
will not be in the MCU I can't say
anything about that and then just pauses
for a minute with a smile like oh wait
no I'm not allowed to say that in
chuckles like oh he just kind of gave
something away that little twinkle in
his eye was probably something about a
clause in his contract that would allow
him to pop up in the Sony spider-verse
movies in some fashion but because I
really don't think that they had figured
it out at the time they just didn't want
to say anything so the
want to pin themselves into a corner
well like six months ago you said that
he was gonna be spider-man in that why
would you change your mind now and just
make fans even madder than they already
were so what happened recently is that
John chef from Collider movie talk was
saying that he had spoken to someone
associated with the venom movie Tom
Horne was seen on set he filmed a couple
days that was gonna be it so their movie
set is set in San Francisco so it's not
like he's just gonna be wandering around
randomly because they're finishing up
infinity war and Avengers 4 so he's been
busy filming that stuff for the past
year it's not like he has a ton of free
time to just go hang around on other
people's movie sets so I'm sure you have
all kinds of questions about you know
what that means for MCU venom because
Peter Parker is essentially connecting
these two universes even though I think
that Sony spider-verse
is going to coexist with the MCU the
same way that Marvel's TV characters
coexist with the movie characters so
think about it this way Marvel TV is
connected to the movies but the movies
don't ever reference what's going on on
the TV shows the TV shows just sort of
play off of what happens during the
movie so the movies Drive everything so
what will probably happen is is that
when they absolutely have to reference
shared events they will reference stuff
that's happened in the MCU like there's
Planet of the symbiotes stuff happening
alien invasion of symbiotes would be a
pretty big deal so Tony Stark the
Avengers Black Panther and Wakanda they
would all probably hear about something
like that so you can see some of the
logistical challenges that they face
there's also the question of the origin
of the symbiote because we know
spider-man is gonna be in Avengers 4 be
pretty big character he will be in outer
space with the guardians of the galaxy
we've already seen footage of it so they
could use some sort of post-credits
stinger to tease symbiote related stuff
and then just follow up with that with
the venom movie like they can do
whatever they want to with venom just as
long as there's a little bit of
connective tissue and that's where Tom
Horne comes in and because of Tom
Hollands age they are kind of pinned
down to a certain time frame like you
couldn't do old man Peter Parker unless
you really spent a ton of money to age
him up which I don't think they're gonna
do so it sounds like they're gonna do a
James Bond caught new anything whereby
you acknowledge stuff that's been
happening
but you're relatively loose with your
continuity so that Sony can do its own
thing with these movies Kevin Feige can
give them the advice when he needs to
then Tom Hollen can go back to MCU stuff
when it comes to sinister six and other
characters crossing over I think it's a
case-by-case basis because Sony gives
Marvel access to spider-man and what
characters it needs in exchange for
Marvel giving them access to Avengers
level characters for the main spider-man
films but that's it like part of the
deal for them sharing spider-man with
Marvel was that they would have Iron Man
pop up in the movie to prop up the box
office just in case people weren't
totally down with Tom Holland which they
were it ended up going fine but the deal
continues with the next spider-man movie
so they have access to another a list
Avenger so if that works really well and
they like that sharing arrangement they
might open the doors for more Marvel
characters to cross over to Sony's
spider-verse if it's relevant to
whatever story they're doing but I think
for the most part functionally if
someone asks you if venom is connected
to the MCU you can say that it's
connected but you can't really say it's
inside the MCU like they're not going to
be acknowledging every little thing that
happens that does not even get in to
what's going on with the x-men movies
now keep in mind the Disney's buying Fox
that does not give Sony in the
spider-verse
access to the Fox characters but again
if Sony makes another deal with Marvel
like hey you have all these extra
characters that you're not using right
now you're not making a ton of x-men
films can we borrow some of them for our
spider-verse
that's always possible but I think the
real question that everyone just wants
to know is is where does the symbiote
come from and how do you trace the
lineage through spider-man if he's gonna
be in Avengers 4 in outer space would it
not make sense for the symbiote to pop
up somewhere for them to tease it being
alive and just latching onto his hand
and then just cutting to black you you
don't have to do a big scene where you
explain him getting rid of it or
anything like that
whatever scenes that Tom Holland has
been filming you can provide some
connective tissue to the Life Foundation
which is the organization in Marvel
Comics that's responsible for creating
the spawn of venom symbiotes
that venom then has to go after but
again just a reminder that only Tom
Holland was seen on the set not Tom
Holland wearing the spider-man
costume so when you hear people say that
it's been confirmed that spider-man is
appearing in the venom movie really it's
only been implied that Tom Holland is
going to appear as Peter Parker in the
venom movie remains to be seen if they
put them in a costume you don't
absolutely have to but if you're gonna
use Tom Holland you do have to explain
where the symbiote came from if it's not
gonna come from Avengers 4 in some
post-credits stinger and you're gonna
have to find some way to invoke the
comic book story small changes to the
comics totally okay just as long as
Peter Parker has some sort of implied
prehistory with the symbiote before
Eddie Brock gets a really good example
of a small change is giving Eddie Brock
more of an agent venom backstory as
opposed to being a photographer just
like Peter Parker I think they want to
make it a little more relevant so he's
ex-military
and gets drummed up into this experiment
where he gets the Venom symbiote just
have to link it to Peter Parker somehow
and I think that fans will be okay with
some other minor changes but let me know
in the comments Peter Parker in the
venom movie how do you want them to
invoke the symbiote like how do you want
them to explain where it came from and
how Eddie Brock gets it there is a whole
bunch of other Marvel stuff that just
drops so I'll try to get to that as fast
as possible
new flash episode tomorrow and there's a
new round of that Infinity Gauntlet
giveaway all you have to do to enter
just be a subscriber and leave a
spider-man related comments on the video
congratulations to the winner from that
black panther video that i just posted
Oathkeeper please private message me so
I can get your contact details click
here for that badass new black panther
video and click here for that venom
teaser thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
[Music]